Paul, how you doing? Are you uh you
Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> Awesome, man. Awesome. You a Quran only
a Nation of Islam?
>> Man, I'm just I'm just a old boy from
Detroit that's a Muslim.
>> All right. So, do you agree that the
Bible is the authority over the Quran
>> based on your belief? Yes.
>> No, not based on my belief. Based on the
based on the Quran. So based on that
scripture you wrote that you uh reset I
would say okay it is the authorative
figure of uh what's justified based on
the Quran.
So what happened was the prophet
Muhammad he received he he received a he
received something that he wasn't sure
about and that was a class when he says
say he is Allah who is one Allah
meaning he's the eternal absolute lam
he begotten beggetth nor was he begotten
and there is none unlikely him. So the
prophet was confused. Prophet Muhammad
he was confused. So he said you know
what based on that verse that was God
gave him. He went to the people who
actually uh read the scriptures from
before and when he went to them they
told him yeah this is correct.
>> So he'll know that what the Quran is
saying is correct by going
>> they confirm that God does not have a
son. Well, hold on asked Paul. Paul,
please focus on what I asked.
>> Yeah.
>> According So, according to what you
said, it's the previous scripture that
determines that the Quran was true,
right?
>> It is the previous No, it is those who
wrote who who read the scriptures, the
previous scriptures. That's what it says
in
>> Arabic. Where where are they getting
where are they getting their sources
from?
>> They're getting it from the Jews and the
current Christians.
>> Those are the people. Where are the Jews
and the Christians in this time? Where
are they getting it their information
from?
>> So at that time they got it directly the
followers of Christ and the followers of
Moses.
>> Where did they get it from?
>> They got it from the angel and they got
it from the Torah
>> but it was not at that time it was not
called the New Testament. Neither was it
called the
>> No worries just let's call it the Torah
and Gospel. So the Torah and the Gospel
are the were the determiner on whether
or not the Quran was true or false in
this. Right.
>> Right. But no, let me hold on one second
because when you read in the Quran, it
says the people who read the scriptures.
So it was those it wasn't about the
book. It was that based on the
confirmation of those who read the
scriptures
>> who are getting So they're getting their
information from the scriptures, right?
>> Yeah. Those who read it. So they they
are confirming the scriptures that was
given to them before the Quran was
revealed.
>> Yes.
>> So they're reading the scriptures before
the Quran was revealed. And so when
Muhammad is uncertain about what the
Quran is saying in some places,
>> yes,
>> Allah encourages him to go and ask those
who read the scripture before you. So
that when he sees that, they're going to
tell you that what you're receiving in
the Quran is the same thing that they
have in their scriptures.
>> Correct. Correct.
>> So with that being said, he'll know,
okay, good. Then I I am a pro I am
receiving it from God. This is true.
He'll have no reason to doubt anymore.
Right.
>> Based on their confirmation. They are
>> based on their confirmation.
>> They're they're there to confirm.
>> Exactly.
>> Now correct. Absolutely. So if he goes
there to them and he and and they say,
"Well, actually, hold on. This isn't in
the Torah and the Gospel." Right. So he
finds out from them that what he's
receiving does not match what they're
reading from. then his doubts would be
confirmed in the Quran.
>> Correct. He'll know the Quran is false.
>> Absolutely.
>> So that means that the determiner or the
standard of truth according to this
verse is the Torah and the Gospel.
Right.
>> That's based on the confirmation of
those who read those books which is the
angel and the Torah. I'm you're
repeating it again and I'm saying yes.
>> Okay. So you agree with me? I agree with
that ayat in there.
>> Yeah, you asked a question. One second.
You asked a question. So now I want to
come back and come back with you on
something.
>> So this is live. We know that this
prophet was real. Whether you say he was
false or he was correct. He was a a
prophet of of Allah or not or you know
of God, right? The father. Prophet
Muhammad in that case he followed the
commandment whether he knew it was real
or not. He conf he went he had to go and
do that. Correct.
>> That's what the verse said.
>> Cuz if he didn't do it, then he didn't
follow God's command. Correct.
>> Correct. Yep.
>> Yes. So the prophet Muhammad, he went to
those people with those ayats that he
was not sure of and they confirmed that
it was true. If they did not confirm
that it was true, then he would have
been exposed at that time as a false
prophet or a person who is saying
stories that he had no knowledge of and
he was not sure of. Right? That's just
like uh Moses. That's like Snoop Dogg.
We have people in the generation,
everybody knows who Snoop Dogg is, but
nobody knows. Some people don't know who
is Slick Rick. So I if I'm in a vicinity
where Slick Rick, right, uh, nobody knew
he came out in Are you familiar with who
Slick Rick is?
>> No, but it's okay. Go ahead.
>> See, you don't even know who Slick Rick
is. But if you was to go and ask Snoop
Dogg, Snoop Dogg would say, "Hey, I
don't even Some people also don't know
who Slick Snoop Dogg is." So I would
say, "Okay, go ask that old Go ask that
old head who is who have you heard of
Slick Rick?" He'll say, "Yeah, I know
who Slick Rick is." Right. So I just
wanted to answer that that yes the
prophet Muhammad he went to those who
read the scriptures and they confirmed
everything he said was correct.
>> All right. So when we go to the previous
scriptures when we go to the Torah and
gospel and we see side by side we check
the stories of the prophets. We check
these ayat. We check what Muhammad was
revealed to see if it matches with
what's in the Torah and the gospel. um
we see these things that Muhammad
contradicts of the Torah and the Gospel.
And so we have to determine that the
Quran is false, that Muhammad is not a
true prophet because he's going against
the Torah, the message of Moses and the
prophets, and he's going against the
gospel, the message of Jesus.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. Like for example, Jesus says that
he's the son of God and his gospel.
Muhammad obviously is teaching in the
Quran that Jesus is not the son of God
and whoever says though so is cursed and
deluded. That's chapter 9 verse 30. So
example like that we see that Muhammad
is contradicting Jesus and therefore is
a false prophet. What do you think? So I
go back to the scripture that you quoted
in the Quran about Jesus God Allah
instructing Muhammad to go to the people
who know who read the scriptures i.e.
the the injil and the Torah. Those
people lived maybe 700 years 800 years
before you even existed. So we're that
text is specifically talking about the
Christians and the Jews of the time of
Muhammad that was amongst him and
amongst the pagan Arabs who did not
believe in these stories about Moses and
then these beautiful stories about
Joseph. So and also other things like
God is one that there is only one
creator. So what happened? God. He said,
"If you are in doubt, Muhammad, go to
those people." So, he went to those
people at that time, not what you're
talking about now. So, you personally
have your right to say what you like to
say. No worries. But
>> so, you're saying that the Torah and the
Gospel in Muhammad's time is not the
Torah and Gospel that we have today.
>> I didn't say that. I said I specifically
said those people who were of the script
who read the scriptures of that time
they agreed with Muhammad and they
confirmed what Muhammad saying is
correct.
>> No they didn't
>> and they are Christians and Jews.
>> No they didn't.
>> Were you there?
>> Well they the Quran even says that
>> well if they said they if they said no
>> fables
>> then no that defeats his purpose of
being no that means he was a liar. He
was exposed.
>> He was a liar. Yes. Well, that at that
time they said no, he wasn't. They
confirmed it.
>> Oh, they did. They said that he's a
>> They did. They confirmed it.
>> They confirmed it. All right. Where
where did they confirm it?
>> They confirmed it because he because
Muhammad went to them.
>> You have a verse cuz I I have verse
Muhammad went to them and they confirmed
it.
>> All right. Where do you have a verse
that
>> if he did if he did not go to them, he's
not following the Allah. Correct.
>> So, do you do you have a verse?
>> Do you have a verse? Do you have a verse
where the
>> confirmed? Anybody can get can bring
narrations and stories. So, we're
talking about the Quran specifically for
what you mentioned.
>> Yes. Does the Quran say that they
affirmed him and they believed in him?
>> Does the Bible say that they confirmed
that that Muhammad went to them?
>> The Bible reject
>> they confirmed. They said no.
>> The Bible rejects somebody like Muhammad
coming. It says it warns us of false
prophets. He's losing connection.